This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Sam.
And I'm Neil.
In this program, we're finding out all about food flavours.
Although everyone knows what food they like the taste of,
the science behind flavours is complex.
Flavour involves much more than tasting with the tongue.
It's also influenced by how food looks, smells,
and even how it's described.
In this program, we'll be meeting the flavourists,
scientists who combine different natural and artificial ingredients
to create the flavours we love to taste in our food.
And of course, we'll be learning some new vocabulary as well.
Sounds delicious, Neil, but first I have a question for you.
No one really knows why, but certain flavours seem to work well together.
Some scientists think classic combinations like lemon and lime,
or strawberries and cream are so popular because they're chemicals over lap in special ways.
Sometimes this creates new, interesting, and unusual flavours.
So what weirdly popular combination was invented by British chef,
Heston Blumenthal?
Was it a, dark chocolate and sea salt?
B, milk chocolate and chilli or C, white chocolate and caviar?
Well, I've tried sea salt and chocolate, I think it tastes great.
So I'll say A.
Okay, Neil, I'll reveal the correct answer at the end of the program.
Nowadays, the flavour industry is big business.
Flavourists work in high-tech laboratories,
and every new ice cream, crisp or two-paste flavour,
is the result of years of scientific research.
But it wasn't always like that.
Here's food historian Dr. Nadia Berenstein
describing the beginnings of the flavour industry in the 19th century
to Ruth Alexander, presenter of the BBC World Service Program, the food chain.
There's really only a handful of people,
and maybe a dozen or so companies that are really involved.
And at that point, they really are kind of working with secret recipes
that were kept very secure and sometimes passed down
within families from father to son.
So it really seemed like a guild structure from the middle ages at that point.
Was it seen as some kind of dark art?
Yes, the term black art does come up in some of the early writing
of people who were producing flavours at this point.
To begin with, there were only around a dozen, that's 12,
companies experimenting with food flavours.
The recipes they used were kept secret and only shared with family or trusted friends.
Dr. Berenstein compares these companies to a guild,
an organisation of people who do the same job, or have the same interests.
Because it was so secretive and mysterious, people saw making flavours as a dark art.
A method of achieving something in a clever but dishonest or wicked way.
But all this changed after the Second World War,
when the invention of processed food, which could be bought in supermarkets and kept fresh at home
in the fridge, increased the demand for new and exciting flavours.
Here's Dr. Berenstein again, explaining the work of present day favourists to BBC World Service
programme, The Food Chain. So essentially becoming a flavourist today is still an apprenticeship process.
There's no academic path to it, right? Your training is on the job, working alongside
a master flavourist, at a flavour and fragrance company, or at some of the bigger
food companies will have their own flavour divisions.
It's a scientific profession for sure. You have to know a lot about chemistry,
but it is a creative profession. That the very heart of this industrial food system,
there's these craft artisans who are essentially designing a molecule by molecule,
the flavours that shape the way that food is made to taste.
Today's flavourists learn their art by serving an apprenticeship.
A period of time spent working for a skilled master, often for low payment,
in order to learn their skills. Although a background in chemistry is important,
you can't study flavours at university. The training happens on the job, actual place of work,
while you are working. Dr. Berenstein calls favourists craft artisans, people doing skilled work
with their hands, and she describes their creations as the marriage of science and art.
Yes, I love the idea of the flavourist as a magician adding a pinch of this flavour or a drop of
that oil to create the perfect magical taste. I wonder if that's what British chef
Heston Blumenthal was trying to do. In my question, I asked what popular flavour
combination was invented by chef Heston Blumenthal? And I said it was A, dark chocolate and sea salt.
So was I right? It's true that sweet and salty flavours go together well, but the correct answer was
white chocolate and caviar. A combination described by Swiss master flavourist,
Francois Benzzi, as weird but wonderful. Right, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned
starting with a dozen, which means twelve. Something described as a dark art refers to a method of
achieving something in a clever but dishonest way. A guild is an organisation of people who do the
same job. An apprenticeship is the period of time an apprentice spends watching and working
with a skilled master in order to learn their skills. When you do something on the job,
it happens in the workplace while you're working. And finally an artisan is a person doing
skilled work with their hands. Once again, our six minutes are up. Bye for now. Bye bye.